in this video we'll talk about
pseudogenes pseudogenes are
non-functional segment of DNA that
resembles functional genes so here we
have a protein coding Gene a and on the
right hand side we have a pseudogen for
protein coding Gene a so pseudogen has a
lot of sequence similarities with the
protein coding Gene however there are
some differences
so pseudogenes are usually identified
when genome sequence analysis finds
gene-like sequences that lack regulatory
elements so if you notice here the
pseudogen of Gene a doesn't have the
regulatory promoter element with it so
most likely it's a pseudogene most
non-bacterial genomes contain many
pseudogenes and
they are as many as the functional
protein coding genes question is what
are their functions are they
evolutionary relics their consequence of
an accident or they have defined
functions
various biological processes are
expected to create pseudogenes for
example retrotransposition
now directs there exists no specialized
mechanism by which these kind of like
pseudogenes can be removed from the
genome
pseudogene was first discovered by Jack
etol in 1977 from xenopus in the
xenopause the 5S ribosomal RNA Gene has
a pseudogene
and this particular pseudogene
was identified by Jack it all they
didn't know at that point of time that
what was the function of these Gene
these days it is involved in immune
function it is annotated but that time
they didn't identify a function of these
Gene and that's why they thought okay
acetogenes are kind of genes which has a
structural similarities with a normal
Gene but they are functionless so kind
of they are evolutionary relics
okay there are different kinds of Co
genes but question is what are the
factors that can distinguish them
from a protein coding Gene there could
be absence of introns the lack of
regulatory sequences like promoter
elements and the occurrence of
truncations or disruptions of open
reading frame due to mutations are
predominant feature of pseudogenes
now gen code uh
consortia had named specific genes as
pseudogenes and annotated them
throughout the human genome it turns out
human gene has a genome has almost like
10 000 or more pseudogenes that's a lot
let's talk about the types of pseudogene
there are two types of pseudogenes
processed pseudogene and unprocessed
pseudogene processed pseudogene are
consequence of retrotransposition where
the RNA of a particular Gene is
transcribed and later on the cdna
corresponding to this RNA is now
incorporated into a new location which
has created the
pseudogene but it lacks the promoter
elements because the MRNA won't have the
promoter right
now the unprocessed pseudogen also might
have promoters but they are as a they
are occurred due to a result of
duplication so they accumulate mutations
in their reading frame so they might not
produce functional protein or might
produce a protein which are having
different function
so let's talk about the functional
aspects of pseudogene
though initially pseudogenes were
thought to be non-functional and they
are just a outcome of some accident
it's not true
pseudogene performed many function
pseudogene could be a source for long
non-coding RNA
pseudogene could regulate gene
expression it can repre it is known to
repress many genes in the genome so it's
it is having a CIS regulatory element
like function
also it can interfere with parent mRNA
that means you know if the particular
pseudogene is transcribed in the reverse
Direction so basically the antisense
trend is now transcribed so the sense
and antisense strand can hybridize with
each other which would sequester the
normal mRNA of that particular Gene and
prevents translation so overall
translation rate would be impeded by the
presence of the pseudogene
so these are few identified function of
pseudogene and active research is going
on to identify many more new functions
but there are a lot of difficulties in
terms of studying pseudogenes think
about microarray so a particular Gen X
and the CO2 Gene of that particular Gene
would have sequence similarities that
means if we use a specific probe to
identify these genes the pseudogene
would also get hybridized so it is
really hard to discriminate between the
Gene and the pseudogen not possible with
micro array
then there is short rate RNA sequencing
in the short read RNA sequencing as well
due to the problem in terms of base pair
resolution one can't find out that what
are the differences in terms of base
pairs in a short read so these are
fragments so if we look at the fragments
a gene fragment versus a pseudogene
fragment would pretty much look like the
same
so that is why it's really difficult to
identify with them in RNA sequencing as
well because RNA for both Gen X and
pseudo Gen X would have a lot of
similarities and very little differences
between them maybe the differences are
in order of base pairs
it's also difficult to knock down CO2
genes if you want to understand what is
the function of pseudogen you have to
knock out or knock down them so if you
design a sirna complex to Target the
pseudogene you would also
non-specifically Target the gene
corresponding to that pseudogen so off
targeting would be a huge issue and you
cannot determine what is the function of
the pseudogen these days crispr cas9
based technique is bit better to study
pseudogenes and their function
I hope this video was informative if you
like this video give it a big thumbs up
don't forget to like share and subscribe
and please share my videos with your
friends support our Channel using super
thanks see you in next video